oh non l'échec e vo matin bonjour brise
c'est un retour celui de borat 14 ans
après le film devenu culte
sacha baron cohen revient avec la même
méthode il se déguise en faux
journaliste kazakh et on peut juste
avoir un regret c'est que ce film sorte
justement pas au cinéma
juste parce qu'on n'aura pas le plaisir
de voir cette affiche là mettez masque
sauver vie je reçois en étrange clown ce
soir la place de marseille ou du chef
service aux codeurs t elle mais ok et
vous monsieur un journaliste économique
c'est donc mire toi marciel ligne où
vous vous l'avez fait en vrai ce test je
les fais un vrai j'ai même mis le test
dans le film mais non ce qui m'intéresse
c'est même à 35 % en espagne rim est
nommé mais voit pas on va pas faut pas
trop dire parce que c'est dans le film
derniers pas de danse avant au moins six
semaines de fermeture
strasbourg relève une dernière fois son
verre avant l'entrée en vigueur du
couvre-feu
les boissons ont ce soir un goût amer
est vraiment prise on retrouve
et le message c'est vraiment travail
transports dodo kg
il y a
c'est vraiment déprimant par les banques
nous impose d'être caution personnelle
en engageant nos biens personnels ça
veut dire que si demain
même ma structure ll est en cessation de
paiement ça veut dire que ma vie
complète s'effondre ah bah je suis
triste car pardon et maintenant c'est la
séquence sensation de l'émission nous
allons vraiment faire peur aux
téléspectateurs s'entend sur nos lèvres
noaa
voilà il fait le mieux le garder voilà
pourquoi aussi à la fin du film de
génériques et en français vous êtes en
train de vous dire là bas on sait que le
générique on dévoile rien c'est bien de
le dire parce que parfois des gens qui
s'en vont et qui voit pas les chiffres
et moi ça fait deux je travaille pas
pour l'argent aujourd'hui je connais pas
mon salaire je travaille on donner du
sourire aux gens ce monsieur bonjour
en quoi je suis je vous renseigner
monsieur je vend des voitures sans
permis donc nous avons celle-ci jantes
alu radar de recul bluetooh du sud
quartier
[Musique]
c'est incroyable parce que
voilà le cas c'est laurent me font
démonstration de
avant première à dire dans le train et
les passagers ne bouge pas c'est comme
si c'était normal c'est extraordinaire
tout va bien pour rester dans la voiture
d'orient malheureusement perdre aucun
mail vous êtes éliminés
entre ciel et ce dès le elle était
sortie en 1re lettre dans éléments des
doigts alors sais pas si je vous ai pas
parlé
excusez moi sébastien c'est pas parce
que vous avez élimé arthur et m'aurait
jamais parlé comme ça jamais et art sur
lui au moins il va vous faire une boule
à neige alors que vous tiens rien walou
madame vous l'avez constaté il ya
quelques minutes lors de l'épreuve
d'immunité
l'émotion était très importante au
moment de l'élimination de bertrand
kamel mais il y tenait à aucun moment
son flambeau n'a été éteint en tout cas
on se souviendra d'un aventurier
charismatique bienveillant et talentueux
[Musique]
juste avant la publication de cette cet
opuscule à strasbourg un pape avait
fulminé une bulle disant que les femmes
étaient toutes des sorcières c'est comme
ça que ça c'est le pape qui est
responsable quand même là après bah oui
c'est pas la peine de rigoler désolé je
retire rien touché coulé la renarde si
je peux me permettre
comment est-ce qu'on définit une
sorcière alors bonne question
premièrement vous la mettiez en face de
vous et vous lui demandez de pleurer si
elle ne pleure pas c'est une sorcière
si elle pleure c'est peut-être des
fausses larmes à ce moment là il faut se
remettre voix de dieu et si elle ne
pleure pas du tout vous êtes sûr que si
vous êtes succès des vraies larmes
c'est pas une sorte le real à commande
comme ça sans raison oui oui comme ça
d'accord c'est quand même la créatrice
du caleçon enfers de confiance c'est
quoi as tu viens chaque fois qu'il ya un
bug et vous quel intérêt si tu attendais
pas je te présente regarde nous avons
inter moi je pense en fait que c'est
important d'avoir quelque chose qui
réponde présent et
du coup voilà moi demain je kiffe en
fait d'avoir une grotte je rappelle que
vous venez de belgique
tous les deux nous exactement vincent
les nus près de mons ok nicolas moi
j'habite couillet comment j'avais
couillet dans la région de charleroi et
comment s'appellent les habitants
fuyaient les couilles et toi et couilles
étoiles a évidemment voilà que l'on
embrasse et que l'on salue sks qu'énorme
genre une norme moi même c'est très cm
la norme
14h34 c'est gros plus haddock
ll est presque plus grande qu'au bout
finalement salut drague
alors la terreur ça va toi il calme
aujourd'hui
à la tortue c'est le seul animal que les
enfants auront le droit de toucher même
cet énorme mal de près de 300 kilos que
les soigneurs ont baptisé table basse
le premier à se lancer dans l'aventuré
c'est le dragon lorsqu'il vient me
qualité les excès news donc on la
rédaction avait des portes vitrées mais
sans tain c'est à dire qu'on voyait à
l'extérieur mais je ne voyais pas et à
l'après midi devait arriver ce qui est
arrivé
un jeune couple s'est glissée entre de
deux poteaux et a fait l'amour devant
toute la rédaction
non si et c'était il n'a jamais entendu
parler ce histoire parce que maintenant
vous me révéla c'était très longtemps et
qu'on va retrouver les étais et c'était
mignon et puis on les a laissé faire
parce que on a détourné le regard et on
a attendu que ça se passe voilà